okay so if anyone's seen the boron video
out there you're going to know that I
love boron I also put boron to our
halide on the Christmas tree at
Christmas and this is because boron is
still an element that's very close to my
heart
because that's what I did my PhD on and
I also did a postdoc so I was
researching boring for a long long time
and I'm still very interested in the
chemistry of boron
I've never seen boron tribromide though
I lecture about it and about molecules
like it's have brought broke boron with
three chlorines or fluorines or
bro-beans
so I thought I'd show you the way I
teach about it I have this model so it's
boron with three bromine Zhan it
allegedly or on tribromide is a
colorless liquid it's supposed to be
when it's pure so this is our boron
tribromide that are as you see it's
orange you can see it's a triangle of
metal and the idea is that this is a
model of the molecule with boron in the
middle and then I can take a pen and
draw on the bro means here here and here
you put the boron middle and you control
the bonds so it's actually
light-sensitive so we're storing it
under under foil usually if it's out in
the light it's a little bit like
sensitive so what we get into a little
bit of for a bromine formed in our boron
tribromide this could also be leftover
you buy it and it is orange as well
actually so it's probably a little bit
of bromine left over for when it was
synthesized in the first place by the
chemical company what I'm hopefully
going to show you today it usually does
it anyway it usually reacts very quite
quite quickly with air and the moisture
in the air but mostly the moisture is
that boron will for and tribromide well
whew okay
it usually blocks up our syringes and
stuff so I'm hoping it's going to fume
today so the reason I have this is to
show my students that when I rotate the
molecule round it looks the same so the
molecule was just like a flat triangle
with three bonds and the boron in the
middle and if you look at the dead John
it's completely flat well there's a
little knob here you'll notice that
we've got this fancy thanks to get up
going again so we have what is called
the shape line setup this is because we
can't have boron in
in in oxygen-poor on in especially in
wet oxygen because it will react with it
and we want to keep our our compound as
nice and pure as possible so my students
can use it for their reactions so if I
put a bit of argon on hopefully and find
out which line this actually comes from
but the knob here is quite useful
because it also indicates the students
that the boron doesn't have the maximum
amount of number of electrons around it
they could do so there's a possibility
of some molecule that has extra
electrons like ammonia coming in and
attacking and giving some of its
electrons to them and when it does
happen you get a molecule like this one
where here you have the boron which has
had two electrons given to it by the
ammonia this is a syringe
obviously boron Triborough mines and
liquid it actually melts it I think
about 40 minus 46 degrees and so in room
temperature it's our liquid so we can
actually syringe it around I'm going to
put this superseal in the top just so we
don't let any air go in and then I'm
gonna syringe out a little bit and just
put it in this watch glass and hopefully
it will do some fuming we're now opening
up our tap okay so actually if you can
see carefully you can see the fumes
coming out the top already
so this donates electrons and the boron
accepts electrons it's a so-called lewis
acid that's a molecule that accepts a
pair of electrons and you can see when
it pairs accepts these electrons the
bromine czar forced downwards so instead
of being flat now it's shaped like a
tetrahedron that's a ball with four
equally spaced groups around it that top
is gonna stay on
so what we'll do
it will flush this out with argon a few
times so you've got argon gas going
through this okay so i'll Gon's an inert
gas it doesn't react with anything one
it's not not a room temperature anyway
so if we flush it out with a bit of
argon what I'm going to do is to take a
little bit because we don't need much of
this don't waste too much of it once
it's in the air it's useless so I'm
hoping that some of it will come out
there's a little bit of it Lewis after
whom the Lewis acids were named was a
very interesting chemist he died in the
late 1940s about the year I was born he
was found dead in his lab possibly with
his mouth smelling of cyanide he may
been poisoned nobody's ever quite sure
but he was a very influential chemist he
worked in Berkeley in California and he
was the person that defined what a
chemical bond was in the modern sense
that is two electrons being shared by
two atoms and so every time I think have
bought boron tribromide and similar
molecules Lewis acids
I think of Lewis and what he gave
chemistry
pull this out of here it's a big thick
needle so hopefully that won't get
burned up that went everywhere then
pull that fume hood down so you can see
I splashed a bit there and it's all
there and you can actually see it
reacting with the super seal okay this
is a really really reactive compound so
it's everywhere I'll put that in there
okay so what's actually happening here
is that the boron tribe bromine's is
reacting with the water in the air okay
it's mostly the the moisture in the air
that's reacting with and she's pretty
reactive what we're getting off is hbr
gaseous hydrogen and bromine gas okay
and what you probably see is a white
residue of some sort of boric oxide left
behind but HBR gas this is why boron
tribromide is a toxic chemical is
because HBR gasps what it gives off as
well is also toxic so it's not this is
why we're using a fume cupboard because
it's not not a very good thing to
breathe in at all I later about boron
tribromide and similar ones because of
their shape because of the way they
behave and their simple reactions
chemists like Debbie who make boron
compounds use this as a useful starting
material they can react the comp the
bromide one of the bromine comes off and
they put on some other group and make
more and more complicated molecules so
it's like a starting building block
which they can make more complicated but
I don't study boron chemistry so to me
it's just a triangle of aluminium